The Batman rumors and leaks just keep on coming.
Let's get it out of the way from the start:
potential spoilers for the newest Batman flick
lay ahead.
According to We Got This Covered, sources
familiar with the production are reporting
that the forthcoming film's plot will focus
on the efforts of the World's Greatest Detective
to track down a serial killer on the loose
in Gotham City.
Writer/director Matt Reeves is said to be
taking his cues from the iconic Batman comic
miniseries "The Long Halloween" in crafting
his story.
Previously, separate alleged leaks that hit
the web have indicated that the Robert Pattinson-starring
flick will feature no fewer than six villains,
with the Penguin and Catwoman being front
and center.
Also said to be taking part in the villainous
goings-on: the Riddler, Two-Face, Firefly,
and the Mad Hatter.
Reeves has previously stated that he'll be
going for a much different version of the
Dark Knight than any we've seen on film thus
far, one which will highlight the Caped Crusader's
legendary detective skills.
It'll be a more grounded, noir-ish take on
the Batman mythos than has previously been
explored in the character's multiple cinematic
incarnations.
According to We Got This Covered's sources,
The Batman's plot will follow Bruce Wayne
as he attempts to get to the bottom of a rash
of mysterious murders plaguing Gotham City.
Presumably, this investigation will take him
down multiple paths — and this is where
the flick's large assortment of iconic baddies
could come into play.
The report's insiders assert that, while Penguin,
Catwoman, and the Riddler will be featured
prominently, the remaining three villains
will be relegated to comparatively minor roles.
There's no word yet on whether or not all
the bad guys will be fully fledged villains,
or if they'll be versions of those characters
who have yet to fully develop into themed
super-jerks.
But this wouldn't be the first time a superhero
flick would have a large assortment of bad
guys appearing in various stages of their
career.
Just a couple years ago, Spider-Man: Homecoming
featured the Vulture as the main villain,
but also boasted appearances large and small
from Spidey bad guys like the Tinkerer, Scorpion,
the Prowler, and two Shockers.
That's six villains right there, so the groundwork
for The Batman to follow a similar path to
success has already been laid at the movie
theater.
Overall, The Batman could be laying the foundation
for a series of movies whose antagonists will
have fleshed-out backstories and well-established
motivations — things which other superhero
films afflicted with the dreaded Villain Bloat
have neglected to provide.
We're looking at you, Spider-Man 3.
At any rate, we've previously expressed our
opinion that Reeves — a very capable filmmaker
who knows his way around a good story — knows
what he's doing in taking on the formidable
task of rebooting Batman yet again.
For that matter, while the internet may have
gone temporarily insane when Pattinson was
cast as Bruce Wayne, there's every reason
to believe that he'll absolutely crush it
in the role.
Reeves is a highly competent director of actors,
and he knows just as well as anyone that Pattinson's
filmography — which has featured amazing
turns in smaller, lesser-known films such
as 2017's Good Time and 2018's High Life — has
revealed him to be a much, much better actor
than fans only familiar with the Twilight
series would ever expect.
At this point, we're going to go ahead and
say that if you're not excited for The Batman
yet, it's probably a good time to rethink
your position.
The flick doesn't hit screens until June 25,
2021, and we'll be keeping close tabs on every
bit of information there is to report between
now and then.
Keep an eye on the Batphone in case it starts
to ring…you never know when you might need
to pick up.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your superhero
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.